hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a keynote presentation in
a mechanistic approach to overcoming
antibacterial drug resistance presented
by dr. Neil austra a professor of
biochemistry John Fenoglio chair in
biochemistry at Vanderbilt University
School of Medicine I'm Suzy Valdez
elaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by elaborates Roberts is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
and type those questions into the box
that appear at the screen when I share
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of our presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use that Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the button in
the bottom left corner and follow the
process for obtaining your credits one
last note I'd like to let everyone know
that this today's educational webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
until December 2017 without further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. Neil
Ostroff I will now turn the presentation
over to him welcome sir
hello my name is niala Schroth I'm
really pleased to be able to talk to you
today about some of the work that my
laboratory has been doing at Vanderbilt
University School of Medicine's today
we're going to talk about the
mechanistic approach to overcoming
antibacterial drug resistance
specifically we were talking about
quinolone antibiotics so I want to talk
to you about the drugs and how they work
and some new drugs that are coming up
they can also have the same targets I
want to talk to you about the bacterial
targets we're gonna be talking about
with your DNA topoisomerases and I want
to talk a little bit about the DNA
itself because we need to understand
some properties of the DNA to understand
how these enzymes work so over here on
the Left what you see is actually
eukaryotic so we're gonna be talking
over here about prokaryotic cells the
point still remains the same that all of
your genetic information is embodied in
this one dimensional array of basis a's
t GS and C's but the way it exists in
the cell and the three-dimensional
properties of that DNA really go a long
way toward controlling how the genetic
material is expressed how it's passed in
generation generation so this is
actually an e coli where what you can
see is that the DNA is actually attached
to the membranes and there's a whole lot
stuff in a very small amount of play a
very small area so that ultimately some
of the most important three-dimensional
structures are topological in nature now
basically as long as the ends of DNA are
fixed in space as they are with
bacterial DNA because it's circular it
turns out that topological relationships
are those where you have to cut the
double helix fundamentally this is DNA
we call relaxed
it's got no torsional stress on it but
in fact in all of our systems from
bacteria up to people DNA is under wound
about 6% and we call that negatively
super coiled it can also be overwhelmed
we'll talk about that as well so that
you have this whole range event
information and why is this important
it's important because under wound DNA
can be the double helix be opened more
easily remember DNA the double helix is
actually just the storage form for the
genetic information so to get to that
information we have to be able to pull
the two strands the double helix apart
hence it the DNA is under wound it
again it's important it's good and it
helps you be able to access the
information the problem that you get
into if you look here this would be a
replication fork or just anything that
pulls the double helix apart you're not
changing the number of times the double
helix is turn the number of turns you're
just compressing them into a smaller and
smaller space so the problem you have is
anytime a tracking system that goes
through DNA it could be a replication
fork it could be a transcription complex
the replicas the machinery that proteins
move straight and the DNA spins and so
ahead of this what happens is the DNA
gets overwhelmed when the DNA DNA gets
overrun just like this rope over here
would be the problem is machinery can't
go any further and things will stop so
you have to be able to alleviate this
problem the other thing that happens is
sometimes during replication what
happens is that some of this energy that
you've got over twisting here goes
behind the fork and the two strands the
double heel to daughter chromosomes gets
intertwined inter wound hence you get
what we call cat names where they're
basically interlocked circles the other
thing that happens is them during normal
cellular processes you get knots and
tangles in your DNA just think of it as
having a really really long rope at home
if any of you knit you can probably
relate to this if you have a lot of
broke at a very small amount of took
place ultimately going to get knots in
it and the exact same thing happens in
the cell and the cell has to be able to
deal with this to hear the reactions
we're talking about we have to be able
to take DNA that's under wound or
negatively super coiled which is its
normal state we have to be able to then
take DNA becomes overwhelmed ahead of
things going on in the cell and bring
all these back to something it's more
relaxed at the end of replication
daughter chromosomes are interlocked we
call these cat neens yet be able to pull
them apart and the same thing happens
recombination processes put knots in
your gain and you have to be able to
deal with that as well the enzymes in
the cell that do this in bacteria and
humans are called topoisomerases because
they talk they alleviate topological
stress in DNA these are ubiquitous
enzymes which means that every cell type
has them they all act by generating
transient breaks in the DNA because
the only way if you think about having a
rope that's totally tangled the only way
to get the tangles out of it and then
cell you have to break it pull it apart
put it back together again there are two
kinds of taupe or two classes of
topoisomerases type 1 and type 2 type 1
make single strand breaks hence they can
deal with over and under winding in DNA
type 2 topoisomerases make
double-stranded breaks they can do with
under and over winding but they're the
enzymes you can also take knots and
tangles out for you we're not gonna
worry about the type 1 enzymes today
we're going to focus on the type 2 now
the thing that becomes really important
about these enzymes is when they cut the
DNA you don't want the ends flying off
into space so the enzyme actually forms
a covalent bond between active site
tyrosine residues and both ends of the
DNA that get cut and this covalent ends
on cleave DNA complex is referred to as
a cleavage complex and this is going to
be really critical because this is the
actual target for anti-cancer words a
cancer drugs but also antibacterials
we're talking about today now the way
these enzymes work is this is
topoisomerase to representation down
here is actually a structure of a
eukaryotic enzyme but pretty much the
bacterial look very much very similar so
what you have here is a two halves this
is a double helix here and a double
helix coming out of the board at you and
what happens is you take one of these
double heel seeds you make a double
strand break you pass the other one
through and then it comes out the bottom
of the enzyme so at the end the
beginning of the reaction this hill is
above this one at the end it's below so
the only thing these enzymes do is they
change the spatial configuration of DNA
but they're really important and they're
really powerful enzymes because
basically what they do is they make DNA
completely invisible to itself so you
can appreciate how amazing that would be
if you had a rope and you just pull it
through itself without anything ever
happening now in bacteria there are two
kinds of type two topoisomerases there's
something called DNA gyrase and there's
another one called topoisomerase for
both of these are really important
enzymes gyrus is essential enzyme and
this is an interesting enzyme because
this enzyme can actually under wine the
by itself so it's the enzyme that puts
torsional stress under winding negative
super cross into DNA at the same time
you can remove positive super coils or
over ones that happened ahead of
replication for transcription complexes
topoisomerase 4 is the enzyme that takes
knots and tangles out of DNA and it has
to do with the way these enzymes work
and I'll show you that in just a sec
right here is a representation of a
replication fork so what you see is as
the machinery is moving through the DNA
you get positive super coils which means
you over wind the DNA ahead some of this
energy slips behind and they have what
we call pre Catanese this is where the
two daughter chromosomes are tangled
topoisomerase for works by that
mechanism I just showed you
Gerace works by the same mechanism but
what it does is it takes the DNA it
wraps around itself so it actually
creates a positive super coil so it over
winds the DNA then when it passes it
through it becomes a negative super coil
bottom line is this because of the way
this enzyme can grab two different HeLa
C's it can take them through any place
in the genome so it's really well-suited
to got tangles in the DNA gyrase in the
other hand because it takes wraps around
the double helix it's in really close
proximity can't take out knots and
tangles like this but what it's really
good at is putting negative super coils
in and also taking these positive or
overwhelmed DNA out so this is the one
that's just ahead of a replication fork
usually there's some evidence that
topoisomerase form may be able to sit
ahead of that fork as well but it's the
one that definitely sits behind it and
at the end of replication untangles
daughter chromosomes now one thing you
can appreciate is the fact that these
are really important enzymes we talked
about the fact that they're really
powerful enzymes but the problem is they
in order for the cell to happen they pay
a really dear price because it turns out
these are really dangerous enzymes and
this is where we turn to drugs it turns
out that the only way these enzymes can
work is they make double-stranded breaks
in DNA and the
problem is that the most dangerous thing
you can possibly do to DNA is put a
double strand break in it because if you
see over here if you don't put the ends
together correctly you can lose a big
portion of your DNA you can recombine it
in ways you don't want to so under
normal circumstances these enzymes cut
and they put the DNA back together again
pretty quickly and if that happens give
this nice balance of cleavage and back
to ligation and everything works well in
the cell and and everything's great if
you take the activity way what happens
in the bacteria is you start getting
much slower growth rates if it Jerry's
because it's saying ahead of before
taking out this overwhelm this torsional
stress is accumulating in front and
topoisomerase for what will happen is
you can't segregate daughter chromosomes
so if you start taking away this
activity basically the cells will die of
a catastrophic mitotic failure on the
other side of the equations where we're
gonna play today what happens if you had
let's say a drug that made this enzyme
cut DNA too much so what happens is you
have drugs that will basically interact
with the enzyme but they'll sit right
here where you've cut the DNA
that'll slip in almost like a molecular
doorstop and what they'll do is they'll
prevent the DNA of being closed and what
happens is they keep the DNA open then
and so if anything starts moving through
it which you can appreciate the fact
that it's think of this as a railroad
track and if we take the two tracks
apart and if nothing comes through we
put them back together everything's fine
so we pull them apart train comes
through everything gets revved up now
with the train we're going to be really
concerned about the train the people on
board Freight they're caring and things
like that we're the least thing we're
going to talk about is the track in the
case of us the track is our double is
the DNA in the case of bacteria is their
genome so the fact is that we break the
track that becomes really important the
train itself are related proteins we had
a lot of proteins in this cell but we
only have one set of tracks so because
of that what happens is if you now have
this trapped in this cleavage complex
and some replication complex or
something else comes through it
boom you basically explode your DNA and
bad bad things happen to the cell and
the bacteria start generating an SOS
response with both gyrus and
topoisomerase 4 can lead to mutagenesis
but ultimately fragment the genome and
it causes cell death and that's the way
the drugs that we're going to talk about
work now the drugs are going to start
really talking about our quinolone
antibiotics are really used whether it's
by number of prescriptions or a number
of metric tons or whether it's price
ultimately in America how you cut it
quinolones are one of the most widely
used antibacterials in the world they're
broad-spectrum they're very efficacious
for all antibacterials and they're
really among if not the most widespread
among the among the most widespread
antibacterials in the world if you've
heard of any of these in one you've
heard of a cipro or ciprofloxacin a
somewhat more modern version or leave a
quinn reason this one that's used more
than this today crosses over to
gram-positive a bit better and also it
only required one pill a day where
that's two pills a day
the other ones moxifloxacin which
becomes very important tuberculosis
we'll talk about that what you see down
here this is actually an Athenian
bromide stain gel this is a plasmid DNA
small circular DNA and this is the under
wound or negatively super quote form
this you write down here this is a gel
that will separate things in the basis
of size so what you can appreciate if
something has coiled up because it's
super coiled it'll be more compact this
is nick DNA up here it's bigger so it
runs more slowly and this is linear DNA
where double-stranded cuts been made and
the point of this is now you're looking
at ciprofloxacin and what you can see is
this band in the middle coming up this
is the double strand break and there's
some single strand cleavage going on as
well so once again what these drugs do
is they stabilize this cleave it's
intermediate so now what you do
bottom line you take a critical enzyme
that works in your DNA and you basically
turn into something that chops up the
genome so these are really insidious and
interesting drugs in terms of how they
work now Quinn loans have been around
originally since the 60s they started
really becoming important clinically
with the advent o
morphallaxis and then ciprofloxacin in
the 80s and all what's really good for a
long period of time the problem that
we're having is what we're saying is a
lot of resistance coming in so there are
three ways you can get resistance the
first one has to do with the interaction
between the bacteria the bacterial
enzyme and the drugs I mean you can see
here is a double helix this is actually
that cleavage intermediate from a
crystal structure and you see one drug
and each of those two Sissel binds the
bonds a good cut there's some residues
we'll talk about that you see becoming
mutated in the enzyme and that's so the
target mediated drug resistance is far
and away the most important resistance
that we're saying and for the most part
the most dangerous is that where the one
thing that gives you the biggest
resistance other things can happen you
can have over expression of exporters
from the bacterial chromosome and
there's now plasmid mediated resistance
it's coming up in a lot of species and
plasmids carry proteins or to meet genes
will encode for three different kind of
proteins one is what's called a Q&R
protein which will bind to gyrase or
topoisomerase for in the same place DNA
does so it prevents DNA from binding
their transporter said they'll also
encode and there's an Isetta laces of
also encode that will activate the drug
we're gonna focus today on the target
mediated drug resistance now this the
original model that we're using was
actually bacillus anthracis which is the
causative agent anthrax anthrax is a
really interesting disease today we
think of it mostly as a bio weapon but
the reality of it is is really ancient
roots the most deadly form is
respiratory anthrax which really can be
pretty much 100% lethal of untreated but
it's also an ancient disease
Homer mentioned in the Iliad the name
anthrax actually was coined by
Hippocrates which is I think pretty
amazing and it also goes back this is
also the roots of modern microbiology
and vaccinations the famous experiments
of kokum pasture where they actually
showed that taking sheep and giving them
a mild dose of anthrax
if they recover they became resistant to
it so this is the really very beginning
of immunization the reason this becomes
come up more recently at least in the US
and 2001 letters were sent to members of
government and federal judges that were
laced with the sole synth race of spores
thousands of people were exposed 22
people unfortunately actually contracted
and five died once again unfortunately
the point I'm trying to make here is
that because thousands were exposed
ciprofloxacin is actually the
prophylactic drug of choice and in the
east coast of the United States that
year there was an extra half a billion
to a billion dollars worth of
ciprofloxacin there was prescribed as a
result of this that gives you some idea
of just how important these
antibacterials are now it's been known
for years that there are two residues
that you see a mutated in resistant
forms of either gyrase or topoisomerase
for what is a serine residue and this
isn't what the a subunit
jarasand topoisomerase four of us have
two sub means we're not going to worry
about those very much today but it's
specific serine you see this is where
moods most of the resistant comes and
then there's either an alanine or to me
a Spartacus glutamic acid for amino
acids away that you also see become
mutated the problem was that no one knew
what these were doing and furthermore
the first crystal structure came out and
that's not this one this is a bit more
advanced but the first crystal structure
came out and these residues were closed
but they weren't close enough to really
be interacting with the with the Quinlin
anthemic T riyals part of the problem
was the original structure had
orientation the drug wrong but there
also wasn't quite close enough
there's what's known as the keto acid
right here and it's been known for many
years that this Quiles divalent metal
ions so in the cell or probably
magnesium and there been many papers
published in this but no one really knew
the biological significance of this one
of the structures that came out in this
paper which is actually was head
spirited by Ben backs and clacks of
SmithKline they actually captured this
metal ion in the crystal structure and
what they found and I'll kind of show it
up here is a little bit easier what they
found is that this metal ion had four
coordinated water molecules and two of
them were coordinated by this serine in
this and this acidic residue and those
are shown here in the sequence for a
number of different species and so it
was proposed that maybe this had
something to do with the interaction of
the quinolones to the enzyme so we set
out to look at this and this was really
work that was done by a wonderful
student in my laboratory named Katie
Aldred and ultimately she provided
functional evidence for the existence of
what we call a water metal ion bridge
she showed that she also confirmed that
these two residues anchored this bridge
to the protein and that this was really
the primary conduit for most clinically
relevant quinolones
between the drug and the enzyme so the
interesting thing is you find a lot of
different groups decorating it and they
have influence they have a lot of
influence over pharmacokinetics but
ultimately the reason that you have so
much leeway to decorate this with a lot
of different kinds of groups is that for
the most part minions don't really
interact with the protein this turns out
to be the vast majority of the important
interactions that are going on so the
other thing that was great about this it
shows that resistance and function of
the drug or really inner wound so that
you can't understand what one without
the other put another way by
understanding how quinolones
interact with the enzyme you instantly
understand how the
I'm resistant so we did a lot of work
with this ultimately once an you see it
here this is ciprofloxacin the other
class of drugs I'm going to talk about
because we're gonna use them for part of
this our group of drugs called Qin as
lead ions and this is synthesized for us
by wonderful collaborating rod currents
who's head of medicinal chemistry at
University of Iowa Qin as lead ions were
touted as being very good drugs for a
while they've never made it to market
and it turns out that these could
overcome resistance the reason is these
don't chelate a metal ion but it turns
out that it's not this skeleton that
seems to work well it was this group
over here so it turns out you can
decorate things this would be the c7
position where it's a pyridine and
ciprofloxacin skull we call an EMP group
over here this actually has direct
interactions with the bacterial enzyme
so that you don't have to have the
interaction over here in order to have
the drug to work this one over here
overcomes it the problem with this
interaction over here and probably one
of the reasons why this did not come to
market Katie auger in my laboratory was
able to show that not only will this
interact with the bacterial enzyme but
it will also interact with the human
enzyme which has a lot of homology to
these bacterial enzymes so the problem
was this will cross over into human
systems whereas this one really doesn't
but this will become important because
we can use this set to control to look
at how these actually interact with the
bacterial enzyme now we're gonna switch
over to this point for the rest of the
talk away from bacillus anthracis to
Mycobacterium tuberculosis
now tuberculosis is a very very
important pathogen it's considered today
to be the most deadly disease on the
planet caused by a single infective
agent unfortunate in the last year or
two it just overtook hiv/aids as being
the other they said causing the most
deaths from any single bacterial species
or any viral or bacterial species it's
got a really pretty nasty course of
treatments called the right treatment
it's got rifampicin Isis
isocyanide pira's nmi and and butte all
these are not easy drugs that hf taken
for six months a lot of people have
toxicities or they can't tolerate these
so even though quinolones are not the
first choice for treatment of these
infections they're really used a lot
because when you start seeing resistance
to these or when you start having
intolerance these come up so they're
second line treatment and the one that's
really used the most is moxifloxacin now
it turns out with regards to the
topoisomerases tuberculosis is
interesting for a couple more reasons
one reason is that very often when
patients go in and they have the first
signs of Circulo sious they go to their
physician they have a coffee they have
some infiltrate in their chest they're
quickly diagnosed as having pneumonia
and so what happens they get put it on a
course of quinolone antibiotics or so
they start to feel better but they
relapse and when they go back in
sometimes they find out that actually
the real problem wasn't as they had
pneumonia
they assets per kilo sysm at that point
a relatively large number as many as 15
to 20 percent of those patients will
actually be now resistance to quinolones
after treating them that way so that's
the problem
tuberculosis is really unusual in that
it only encodes gyrase it does not
include topoisomerase for so in this
species
jeurys is sort of a either a hybrid
enzyme or a dual function enzyme it's an
enzyme that it has to work both ahead of
the fork and behind the fork it has to
be able to remove DNA over wines as they
take place but offsets people are not an
untangle so it's not your straight-up
normal run-of-the-mill gyrates versus
run-of-the-mill topoisomerase for the
other thing that makes it very unusual
remember I told you there were two
residues that were really important
there was a serine residue there was an
acidic residue for amino acids away and
you see here bacillus anthracis
and gyrase the Parsee is
sub-units for topoisomerase four and
this shows you taupe-y summaries for
injuries in e.coli and what you see they
all have these look at most species that
they have that but here and turns out in
tuberculosis there's an alanine where
this important serious and as a result
although quinolones work they actually
don't work as well against the burqa
Llosa's and i'll show you that in a
minute as they do against some other
species alright so now what we talked
about is here's that replication fork
again and remember we for women Jerry's
here and topoisomerase for here now in
tuberculosis is only Jerry's all gyrase
all the time and so the nice thing about
it is you only have one target for the
quinolones but nonetheless we really
want to be able to look at this and much
of the work that I'm going to talk about
for this next portion of the talk came
from a paper that was published in PNAS
in 2016 where Katie all agree was the
first author now there's a lot going on
in some of these slides I'll do my best
to work you through them the first thing
we wanted to do is look at the ability
of all these enzymes so we looked at the
wild-type enzyme one where we took we'll
skip this one for a second one here
where that alanine is been mutated to a
valine and where this aspartic acids
been mutated either a histidine or
glassing these are all three very common
resistance mutations that you find in
patients with tuberculosis they go
resistant to quinolones this one here is
not one that you'll ever see in a
patient but here's where we took the
alanine and we put a searing back end to
see what would happen if we had both
residues that were there that could
actually form this watermelon bridge to
see if we would actually make it better
what you're looking at here is an assay
that says what's the ability of all
these different enzymes to allow gyrates
to function properly so we're looking at
here is what we call supercoiling assay
we're taking relaxed DNA with no
torsional stress and we're actually
putting torsional stress and we're under
winding it so what you see is this band
starts moving down to the position of
nail a super coiled DNA
the point of this is that these drugs
are unusual in that the more active
enzyme that you have in a Cell the more
breaks these drugs will create hence the
more lethal they become so you could
very easily become resistant if you had
for example an enzyme that this didn't
work very well so the first thing I do
is make sure all these enzymes work well
the black is wild-type when you can
actually see is all the resistant
mutants actually function as an enzyme
as well or even better than the
wild-type enzyme so that's a really good
thing that's important
alright so legs that some of these
become kind of complicated so I'm going
to try to walk you through it
for all these just remember the black is
the wild-type and here's here's your
logos again so that if we now take any
of these the ones here and in yellow and
green or in red or all come from
resistant strains and these carry the
residues we talked about before so let's
look at ciprofloxacin if this amount of
cleavage that you're inducing remember
the more cleavage you get with the drug
the more lethal they'll become this is
under normal circumstance with the
wild-type enzyme with ciprofloxacin
which is shown here when you see what
the resistant enzymes you get much less
cleavage the fun thing about this is if
you put the serine back and we talked
about so that now you have both residues
can really anchor this drug more firmly
what you can see is actually becomes a
much better target for the drugs so
unfortunately we never see that resist
resist immunity or the anti resistant
mutation coming up in nature but it'd be
great if it could
this is moxifloxacin which is the
clinically relevant drug that's usually
used and what you see here once again
you get okay cleavage maybe even less in
ciprofloxacin you tend to do better with
these resistant enzymes and you do a
ciprofloxacin and once again great
cleavage of you put that serine back in
now an interesting thing here is there
are other ends on it there other
antibacterials and the quinolone family
they're actually used against
tuberculosis they all seem to have
something in the c8 position so we
wanted to look at that now let me go
back here this
that Quinn hassling Diane we talked
about before word this is really the
important player but it also does have
if you notice something that has a
methyl group right here in the c8
position and as I told you before since
it doesn't rely on this water metal ion
bridge it works great against all these
if you take the same core here but now
you turn it into a quinolone from a
pronounced leaned honest tell us that
the three primary the three primary MP
group now what happens is you have a
drug that works pretty well but now the
steering works even better because in
other words everything is working really
well here and it's anchoring to the
enzyme but here now you get another
attachment to the enzyme so it works
even better than it did before without
it if we go back to these two again and
remember I told you that if you look
over here it seems that the quinolones
that they use against tuberculosis
always have something in the CH position
so what we did is we took this methyl
group off the c8 position and said what
happens how important is this for
interacting with the enzyme and it turns
out is actually very important because
if you look here now if we take this Qin
a Sling die on that once again it's not
working - this water metal ion bridge up
here but this portion seems to be
important if you compare what went on
here it still looks pretty much the same
against all the enzymes but now much
less activity so this position the CH
position seems to be very important in
terms of somehow doing something with
quinolone interactions with the enzyme
if you take the same drug now take away
that methyl group but now make it a
quinolone so now can still anchor
through the wood or metal ion bridge you
see something that looks a little
different because now it doesn't have as
much activity he's had before but it
still has decent activity against the
wild-type enzyme because once again it
can use this bridge as shown over here
with a searing it works even better
which is once again something that says
it's using this bridge but against the
mutant enzymes which now it has to
depend solely on that interaction it
works really really poorly so what we
can take away from this is really that
moxifloxacin work maybe a little bit
better against the resistant enzymes and
ciprofloxacin and that you really like
to have something in the CH position
really help drug interactions that's
gonna become really important in a few
minutes all right now how do we know
this water mill line bridge actually
it's functioning we have a number of
different assays that we can look at one
of the ways we ask this is if we mutate
one of the residues here what happens to
the metal ion interactions is it
affected and the answer is yes so for
example if we now take instead of
magnesium manganese so these are not
involved in the act say the enzyme but
the enzyme uses double divalent metal
ions when it's actually working on the
DNA and if you now take manganese what
you see is that if you have this
watermelon bridge intact they can
interact very nicely with manganese you
put the serum back in it works
fantastically well if you think the wild
type enzyme it still works okay but now
if you mutate it so you take this and
you take that alanine and make it a
valine nothing straight line across
higher based on levels of cleavage but
no effect of the drug whatsoever so what
that says is that the resistance
mutations will somehow restrict the
ability of these metal ions to function
properly so that indicates that they're
important the other thing we can do are
metal ion titrations because even though
the active site needs magnesium in this
case it turns out it has a higher
affinity see so you've already saturated
the enzyme at a time you're doing things
on the enzyme you may be doing things on
the drug so what you see here is now if
we take the wild-type and this is a
magnesium titration so how much
magnesium you need to make the drug
enhance cleavage if you now take the
serine so now this should interact more
tightly what you can see as you use
somewhat less magnesium to make it
function but now if you take it and you
make it a valine negative it's much
worse so by looking at that in other
words by changing the way this
coordinates you definitely change the
affinity for the developmental line if
you look at that Quinn a saline diet and
remember that the Quinn housing diodes
don't require this interaction at all it
couldn't care less whether you have any
of these mutants they work all pretty
much the same so
that says that we have a functional
bridge the other thing is in terms that
in some species the bridge is used for
binding like an bacillus anthracis all
the ends on people of death it turns out
Niko is used slightly differently it's
not affecting drug binding it's
affecting the way it's positioned so we
can look at this by doing a competition
assay what we can do is we can say
alright we're gonna take this
pronouncing die on that doesn't need
this water metal ion bridge and we're
gonna induced cleavage with it so we
ready a certain amount of cleavage then
we're gonna back ad ciprofloxacin
against these two mutant enzyme so we
know ciprofloxacin works really poorly
with these so in itself it's not
inducing any cleavage and we're gonna
say can they compete out this way now
sitting down and make it cut less and
the answer is it doesn't do it very well
so that in other words the pronouncing
died on and ciprofloxacin against the
wild-type enzyme pretty much have the
same affinity back a couple slides ago
against this remember this cuts really
well this cuts really poorly and you say
alright can this titrate out the effect
of the quenelle same diode and went you
can see we're going from relative
cleavage of one which is in cleavage
induced with the quinn hassling diode
and it's going down to about seventy
five percent under conditions where we
start with 10 micromolar of the
pronouncing diode and going up to 100
micro molar ciprofloxacin so under the
situation where wild-type enzyme these
guys both seem to work pretty what's the
same now you have a situation where if
you had 10 times more than ciprofloxacin
than the Quinn housing dye and it's only
knocking it down about 25 percent so
what this says is that we know this
doesn't change its binding or it's
interaction with the resistant enzyme
what it really means is a sudden find
very well so with all this goes together
it says is yes in tuberculosis
even though you only have one residue
that's really anchoring the bridge it
turns out that it's still really is
important for the binding of the
quinolones to the enzyme now why is it
that you can take that residue that we
now know was a serine and other species
it's an alanine so it's not really doing
anything
I'm making of putting a valine there
gives you resistance we're not entirely
sure probably cuz the failings so large
or amino acid then is alanine so somehow
go back yeah so somehow putting more
bulk up here is making it so this bridge
can't from form properly is our best
guess I'll show you some structures in a
few minutes and we don't really see the
difference in structures so all right
this is a this a difficult slide is a
really important one so let's go through
it remember we talked about before the
c8 position seems to be important so
what we did we took the ciprofloxacin
core and the moxifloxacin core and we
did put three different things at this
position we put either a hydrogen sweet
but nothing there we put a methyl group
there or a methoxy group there methoxy
just being oxygen to a methyl group
ciprofloxacin itself has nothing there
just two hydrogen moxifloxacin itself
has a methoxy so the nomenclature gets a
little bit confusing I apologize for
that if you look at these this is the
interaction with the wild-type enzyme
the a 2 v mutation that gives you
resistance and then these are 2 and the
this is 1 is in one of the acidic ones
where we're going from aspartic acid to
a glycine the solid symbols are for
ciprofloxacin s derivatives so the black
is ciprofloxacin the blue is the with a
methyl group here and the red has a
methoxy we'll just look at those for a
moment what you see here is this is
ciprofloxacin against the wild type
enzyme and ultimately if you put a
methyl group here it gets better and a
methoxy group it gets even better
against the wild type enzyme so it seems
to promote interactions when you look at
the resistant enzyme it has a bigger
effect because now with the resistant
enzyme ciprofloxacin works really poorly
but now these other two work reasonably
well so I simply putting something to
the c8 position would be thought was
important it shows you can actually over
partially overcome resistance same thing
happens here with its other mutant
so down here actually is it's it's in
this line here will be the wild-type
ciprofloxacin you put a methyl group on
and a methoxy you overcome a lot of the
resistance it turns out this same trend
holds but it's even better with
moxifloxacin so now moxie this is the
open circle so the red now because it
has a methoxy group on there it's a
parent drug and then we can either put
the hydrogen there or nothing or the
blue as a as a methyl group would you
see enough so we're looking at the open
so here it here is moxie flux and with a
wild-type and if you put a if you
basically take actually this is moxie
here you take away the group it doesn't
get much worse but now look what happens
if you just take that methoxy group and
turn it to a methyl group now you have
something that gives you a lot more clay
venus a lot more potent and then the
parent now let's look at the resistance
enzymes and it's even more dramatic
because now if this is the parent drug
moxie flux and you take away that group
right here and it looks like it goes
really very much worse which is the same
thing we showed earlier now you put the
methyl group up here and once again it
is totally a recovery resistance in fact
if you look at it right here if this is
moxifloxacin cleaning the wild-type
enzyme now look at it we guess through
the methyl moxie as we call it against
the resistant enzyme it's doing twice as
well against the resistant enzyme as the
parent drug that's being prescribed
today is against even the wild-type
enzyme the same thing holds with the
other with the other mutation so that in
the absolute really worst case this
still looks against this particular
mutation pretty much better than
moxifloxacin looks against the wild-type
enzyme so basically by its just tweaking
this room ever so slightly we can take a
drug and now make it so that it's
actually working against the resistant
enzyme even better than it does the
wild-type enzyme so we're really excited
cuz we're getting ready to put these
into cell
done that yet we're getting ready to put
them in the cells to actually look and
see if this so holds true now the other
thing that becomes important remember I
told you before that the Queen a Celine
Dion may be one of the reasons and never
was developed this because interact with
the human enzyme we really wanted to
make sure these did not interact with
the human enzyme this is at OPA side
which is a widely prescribed anti cancer
drug same thing we're looking at here
the question is how much of the drug
induced the enzyme to cut the DNA this
is actually a different quinolone that
was developed jointly with Pfizer to
really have activity against human
enzyme you see it works great these are
all the drugs we're talking about right
here so what you can see is that despite
the fact we've now taken the same
moxifloxacin going from a methoxy group
to a methyl group giving something that
gives much better activity against the
bacterial enzyme totally it becomes
resistance to doing it's human enzyme
and the answer is it does refer to
nothing so it would also potentially be
a safe drug the other thing that we can
do something called a persistence assay
and basically what we do is we take high
concentrations of drug DNA and enzyme
mix them together get a high level of
DNA being cut and then we just dilute it
out almost like a washout assay with
cells and we just see how long it takes
this to the case this is over three hour
period of time the only way I'm going to
point out with this is that it turns out
that what we call the methyl mocks in
the moxifloxacin that now has a methyl
group instead of methoxy to c8
in all cases decays the slowest so in
all cases is the most stable enzyme so
that that becomes important as well now
there's some structural work that's be
done we did some things and coordination
with james burgers lab which is now at
johns hopkins tim floor was a postdoc
that did the work and what you see here
is tuberculosis this is actually
moxifloxacin binding in the act to say
one of these cleavage complexes and with
TB jeurys what you see here is that
midline we talked about
and it goes and really well this isn't
overlay of this crystal structure with
that that was done by Ben backs which
was moxifloxacin with with the
topoisomerase for from Asuna back to
baumanis that was the original structure
I showed you before and once you can see
that there's a tremendous amount of
overlap they pretty much look the same
this is what it looks like from above
with with tuberculosis one scene you see
the drug sitting in in the active site
this is also now they did structures
with the wild-type and also when you put
the a back to an s so this when you put
the serum back ends and we know that
drugs work much better against this
enzyme they do here but structurally you
really don't see any difference so the
fact that you only have one residue
that's really anchoring the bridge here
instead of two what you see here it's
still sitting in pretty much the exact
same conformation the other thing you
can see here now it's the methyl group
so this is what we call methyl moxie
over here because it only has some
methyl group instead the methoxy group
and it goes in it looks pretty much the
same and this is the overlay of methoxy
she may have methyl moxie flux into
moxifloxacin and so one thing that we do
not understand is from a structural
standpoint these pretty much all is the
same we were all hoping we find some
residue it was interacting it's not so
we do know that when when you take the
methoxy go to a methyl you get a more
stable complex form we know that can
overcome resistance we know that works
much better against the wild-type enzyme
we're still trying to figure out exactly
why that's the case so for the first
part here that can take aways that in
tuberculosis like in other species this
water metal ion bridge is really
important to anchor quinolone
antibiotics
to tuberculosis gyrase that even though
only has one of the two residues that's
that's attaching the bridge it still
works fine if you do something to
disrupt this bridge either by putting a
bulkier group here or taking away the
functionality of the group over here you
basically get resistance the c7 and c8
positions are really important because
remember moxifloxacin super flux and
also have a different c7 group
and so these are also really important
and that by making actually even
relatively small changes them you can
have a drug that really may overcome
overcome resistance totally so I said
we're really excited about the work
we've been doing with with the methyl
moxifloxacin we've got self set up ready
to go with tuberculosis cells and we're
gonna start doing that in a really near
future so we've got to have maybe add
some more drug discovery thinking about
more also with the group that's a
GlaxoSmithKline their diseases of the
emerging world laboratory and trace
cancerous pain we offset the opportunity
I see you in the mouse models with this
as well so we're actually really excited
to see where this leads us to see if we
really can come up with a quinolone base
drug that will completely overcome
Quinlin resistance in tuberculosis
alright that's the first part this is
the last part of the talk there's a
totally different approach we can take
if we want to even stay focused on on
the same enzyme and there's a class of
drugs that was really came out of
GlaxoSmithKline a number of other
companies are looking at them now they
they're not their own immuno prepare
Dean derivatives they were originally
called NBT eyes which stands for novel
bacterial topoisomerase inhibitors not a
real good name that tells you much about
the structure but nonetheless so-called
NBT eyes these are drugs that really
there's virtually no mechanistic work on
there are some very pretty crystal
structures this one came out of once
again been back to GlaxoSmithKline what
came out of this one is that you only
have one of these NBT eyes sitting in
the active site of an enzyme the other
thing that a few papers have seen is
that they will induce cleavage with some
species the they'll induce those
stabilizes cleaves intermediates to get
more cleavage generated by these type
two topoisomerases
but it seems to be single stranded
breaks and other than that literally
there's no mechanistic work at all now
it turns out that some companies of
GlaxoSmithKline AstraZeneca have some
nbg eyes and clinical trials they're
actually doing extremely well
the other thing that's interesting about
these is even though there's one seeing
the same target they seem to overcome
resistance now at least two quinolones
so now let's look at what's going on
here and once again this is this is from
a group
that's coming out of the disease of
developing world and if trees cantos
laboratory outside of Madrid it turns
out that NBT eyes don't work very well
against tuberculosis so they start to
play with this try to select for things
that work better and so this MBTI is GSK
126 it turns out they have a new class
of drugs that are very similar what you
see over here is this portion the
right-hand ring is a lot of differences
to it
and they call these mgi's or micro
bacterium tuberculosis Jarius inhibitors
now the only work has ever been
published with these is this group took
them and they could show that they had
activity against tuberculosis the actual
cultured Mycobacterium tuberculosis also
worked in mouse models they have some
genetic evidence that says that they're
working against gyrase and they could
also show that it seemed to work against
cells and which of mutated gyrase that
normally give you a resistant to
quinolones that being said there's never
been any mechanistic work at all
published on these and there's also been
no work that directly demonstrates that
they were hence tuberculosis cherries so
we end up in the collaboration with this
group so we decided to be able to look
at this and this is work that's been
done to my laboratory by Elizabeth
Gibson so where's the first work who is
done by Katie Aldrin it's been published
this work is not out yet and hopefully
will be sent off in the very near future
so Elizabeth looked at these three
compounds and once again this is triple
zero 325 and 126 this one remembers the
end BTI which doesn't work as well and
these are the what we call the mgi's and
this just shows you this is just a DNA
control
this is gyrase with DNA and under
condition we're using we're seeing very
little cleavage although it doesn't show
up as well as it should this is
moxifloxacin and you see some doubles
double strand cleavage right here
because this is once again the position
of linear DNA this is an eco r1 cut
standard and
some single strand cleavage but what you
see here with these a lot of single
strand cleavage no double strand breaks
but the triple zero gives you a lot of
single strand cleavage this 325 gives
you okay amounts and the 126 gives you
the least if you look over here these
are the compounds by themselves
interacting with the DNA without the
enzyme because you want to make sure
that these don't have some chemical
reaction going on and indeed you see
nothing happening there at all so the
first thing we can do is confirm that
yes these work and they make single
strand breaks Elizabeth did titrations
and what you see is they're pretty
potent they're as potent or more potent
than then quinolone antibiotics about 20
micro molar these max added maybe 5 to
10 micro molar this is a triple zero
again the 325 the 126 these are the
single-stranded breaks that they're
producing these are the double-stranded
breaks so basically they're only making
a single strand of breaks now one of the
things you really want to look at was
why we're only getting single strand
breaks this is a real critical point and
it could be that you're getting one drug
in the other drug gets really hard to
get in so one thing that Elizabeth did
would say alright we're gonna do two
things we're going to actually two
things here right start instead of using
10 micro let me back up one this so we
get maximum cleave is about 10
micromolar drug we use 200 micro molar
drugs it's 20 times more drug and the
other thing is if you look over time
course for cleavage you max out cleavage
it takes a few minutes to establish
equilibrium maybe five or six minutes so
she went to an hour so she added 20
times more drug and went for at least 10
times longer period of time to see if a
second drug molecule can get in and what
you really see so this is what we had
before with 10 micromolar over that
period of time this is 200 micro molar
really no effect whatsoever so in other
words being that lots more drug cleansed
it for a lot longer and we're not saying
more single-stranded breaks and we're
not saying any double-stranded breaks at
all and that's really the critical point
here that even though we're now going to
much higher constant you liked higher
concentration of longer period of time
no double strand breaks coming up
whatsoever
the other thing is that this enzyme
forget overall catalytic activity needs
ATP under normal circumstance we don't
add it to our system because then it's
doing other things to the DNA so if you
only just want to look at the ability of
the enzyme to come and cut the DNA and
put it back together again we don't have
it
so we said I better add just to make
sure and this is a nice control that
this shows you this in the normal
circumstances flat with no ATP if we add
ATP so now the enzyme is busy
supercoiling of the DNA while it's belts
abilities working on it we're seeing
single-stranded breaks look about the
same and no double-stranded breaks at
all so that's also an important control
I think it's not showing up really well
here but one thing we can take linear
DNA we can have an labeled with
radioactivity we can map sites of
cleavage and what you can see is that we
see several sites of cleavage
moxifloxacin and with these mgi's we can
also see sites of cleavage and to be
honest some are the same and some differ
so we're looking at that a little bit
more as well all the clothing relevant
anti-cancer drugs with the human enzyme
and the antibacterial drugs with the
other gyration or topoisomerase for work
because once again they slip into this
cleavage complex and they prevent the
DNA from being closed
basically the drug interacts with the
protein it also slips into where the DNA
has been cut I think of them as what I
call molecular doorstops think of it as
a door being open you slide your foot in
there you can't shut the door and so
that's what you have so if we look at it
like Gatien assay we can induce the
enzyme to ligate the DNA and this is the
wild type what you can see it comes down
pretty rapidly double-stranded breaks
they're stabilized by moxifloxacin or
shown in blue and if you look at single
strand breaks they're stabilized by the
GSK triple 0 it also inhibits ligation
in fact it looks pretty much just like
matzo flocks and does so once again
these drugs work by inhibiting the
enzyme ability
any back together again okay we once see
if they overcome resistance because
prediction they should and so what you
see here once again single-stranded
breaks no double-stranded breaks but
here in the black is against the
wild-type enzyme and then these are
three of the same enzymes we use for the
last portion this is that alanine that's
mutated in two mutations that the
aspartic acid and what you can see in
all three and all three cases there's no
inhibition of activity whatsoever so
these entirely overcome resistance this
is just as control we'll show you that
now this is once again gsa GSK triple
zero single-stranded breaks against now
the a ninety v mutation these are the
double-stranded breaks nothing happening
but this is against and in this hands
moxifloxacin against this enzyme and
it's really showing you virtually
nothing
so under conditions where moxifloxacin
will work really poorly the mgi's work
really well so that has really good
promise another thing we wanted to look
at is remember i told you that the NB t
eyes were pretty poorly against
tuberculosis we said what about one
that's been selected for working against
tuberculosis so with this triple zero
again and most of the things i'm showing
with triple zero actually all of them
that were showing the triple zero just
as an example we've done it with the
other we've done it with 325 and xt 126
as well and we essentially get the exact
same results so what you see here is
this is its ability to induced cleavage
single-stranded breaks now with
tuberculosis gyrase and now if we look
at the seoul san thrace's topoisomerase
4 or bacillus anthracis cherries or
e.coli topoisomerase ford's examples
it's really doing very little we have
other enzyme you looked at as well and
for the most part these seem to work
very well against tuberculosis now one
of the things about quinolone
antibiotics and that becomes really
important but if you keep in mind the
fact that tuberculosis is something like
a third of the world's populations
affected with tuberculosis
so if the only thing in the world that
these drugs might have a chance of
curing is tuberculosis probably that's a
pretty good deal
the other thing is okay is it still
interacting you can't compete out
moxifloxacin and that's what this data
shows you so that now what we do will
start the experiment this way we take
GSK triple zero we added two gyrase so
now you get very so this is basically
baseline levels of single-stranded
breaks
I mean double-stranded breaks a lot of
single-stranded breaks we now so we did
that because we know we've saturated the
system we can now add moxifloxacin which
will give us some single-stranded breaks
will give us more double-stranded breaks
remember and the previous things I
showed you that at about 20 micro molar
moxifloxacin will give you about 30
percent of the DNA will be cut in
double-stranded breaks so if we were
looking this by itself with the gyrase
without GSK triple 0 in there this would
the moxifloxacin cleavage curve would
look something like this would be up
here and by about here or so it'd be
it'd be a lot more cleavage and what you
see is that moxifloxacin yes can compete
the GSK triple zero double-stranded
breaks go up single-stranded breaks
induced by the mgi's go down but once in
here we're starting with 10 or can be 20
micro molar GSK triple zero to make sure
it's saturated we're getting 10 times
more of the moxifloxacin and what you
can see you're about half way as much as
it would have been with 20 micromoles
before so ultimately it will compete
doesn't compete very well so what this
means to us is that the mgi's binds the
same place on the enzyme more or less as
duda quinolones but they bind much
tighter and they also don't have to have
that water meta line bridge to work the
other thing that i found really
fascinating was the fact that now what
we can do is we can start off we can
take instead of using magnesium as a
divalent medline we can use calcium
calcium the enzyme likes just fine the
only thing is it gives you more base
higher levels of baseline cleavage so
that we can look at things a little bit
differently so we're starting up now
with something like 10% of the DNA or so
is now double strand cleavage and the
absence of the MGI
and so what we can do is we can now add
the MGI and with calcium but you see it
works really well
we're actually cutting getting single
strand breaks and almost 100% of our DNA
loves it but we're focusing on the
double strand DNA because the question
we had is already going in there and
you're using single strand breaks is it
find another you have Cleaves on one
strand you have cleave is in the other
trend and it's inducing Cleaves to one
of the strands but it's not really
messing with the one on the other strand
or is it really somehow taking over the
system and the answer is is taking over
the system because what this shows right
here is when single strand breaks you're
going up double-stranded breaks are
actually dropping so what the means is
that this drug not only will induce the
enzyme to make single-stranded breaks
but it'll actually suppress the other
strands from being cut so that's a
really fascinating mechanistic point
from us it may not have anything to do
with these being used clinically but
it's a fascinating mechanistic point for
us so that we really think it's going on
is there when one molecule goes in and
then it allows the enzyme to cut one of
the two strands once it's cut that one
strand it really is going in and
stabilizing it and somehow changing the
active side of the enzyme so it can't
cut anything else yeah so with that in
mind we have questions one of the
questions is when it cuts the double
helix we know it's making a single
strand to break it's always making only
one of the two strands or this randomly
it doesn't care which of the two strands
of cuts but once it's cut one of the two
strands it can't it can't cut the other
one so we're looking at that now so
really the last thing I wanted to show
you is this that once again if something
is cutting the human inducing the units
I'm the work it's gonna be a bad
antibacterial for obvious reasons so
this is now showing the mg is working
against human topoisomerase to alpha
this is a big charter for anti-cancer
drugs and what you see here this is a
top aside inducing cleavage at OPA site
induces a lot of double-stranded breaks
and induce a single strand breaks at all
so but the really important take-home
message here
none of these MDIs are inducing cleavage
at all with the human enzyme so they
have really interesting potential and as
I said some of these NBT
which is the parent group of this are
actually in clinical trials now and
they're doing exceptionally well
so bottom line is that we really think
we're starting to understand how the MG
is and hopefully the NBT is work we
really want to characterize further the
sites where they cut and the strand
specificity would think they'll be
really important we're doing some
structural studies with these now to see
how they look against the tuberculosis
an enzyme and we really wanted to look
at some comparison to see if they look
the same as the nbg is against the
enzyme and with that I really appreciate
you being here there are a lot of people
to acknowledge this is my lab group and
various iterations this is Katie
Aldridge right here who graduated a
couple of years back she's now got her
own faculty position at University of
Evansville this Elizabeth Gibson right
here I should point out that Rachel
Ashley did some preliminary work and
some other things that touching this she
just graduated as well some of you may
know that we had it just had a total
eclipse of the Sun in Nashville
so these are some of my students now and
that was what the Sun looked like also
we have some really important
collaborators from this project
James Berger and Tim blower who are now
at Johns Hopkins really contributed
tremendously traits cantos laboratory
really helped us tremendously and then
also Rob currents so with that I really
appreciate you listening to me today and
taking the time it's just a reminder if
you have any questions submit them and
I'll do my best to answer all of you by
email so once again thank you for
listening I appreciate you taking time
and have fun at the rest of the
conference and best of luck thank you
very much